we've been a little busy with our guests
we just had a great chat with Brent
Musburger and Jeff Garlin was here in
our number 1 and now I turn to my right
now I find the host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast who is out here getting
set to call Ravens and Chargers for
everybody's listening pleasure on
Westwood One tomorrow good to see you
Ross Tucker yeah absolutely rich thanks
for having me and this has been like
awesome for me since I got here I'm a
huge Goldberg fail okay Jeff Garlin
that's great Brittan Musburger me
kidding me you're look I mean when when
he said to me that I was getting him
fired up over the NFL like the kid in me
who used to watch the NFL today was just
like that is the greatest thing of all I
distinctly remember growing up wanting
to get home from church as soon as
possible yes so that I could watch the
pregame show and hear him say you are
looking live they really had with him in
Jimmy the Greek I mean they herb cross
sauce they had it they had it going back
then man oh sure and uh and and Phyllis
George as well she was and Jane Kennedy
after Phyllis I mean and you know that
you are looking live where that what
that's about right for gambling gambling
right so you know the weather and know
what the weather's that's why he would
say that all the time you are look and I
and I never knew that I did remember
Jimmy the Greek being like he wouldn't
say the spread he'd be like I didn't
beat him not by a lot but by a little
maybe a few poor I met him at Tom used
to do it for ESPN as well and now it's
kind of making a comeback right now I
mean it's pretty amazing all right
you're calling Ravens Chargers this is
just a monster huge game and I don't
know which way to call it right now cuz
the Ravens have been absolutely a
totally different team that is tough
that can hit you in the mouth that keeps
their defense fresh because they're
constantly hitting their opposing
defense in the mouth Lamar Jackson
almost won in in Arrowhead so why
shouldn't he be able to walk in a stub
up just like Case Keenum did a couple
weeks ago and win this game but then
Philip Rivers has been dynamite the last
month what do you make of this game and
I was just thinking this driving out
here feel rich have you ever thought of
a better dichotomy between two
quarterbacks opposite I know I mean they
they couldn't be more different it's
crazy
I love watching the Ravens I mean as a
guy that played offensive line watching
them on tape now rich it's almost like
watching an Academy like army or Navy
like every time they get to third down
it's third in like one two three or four
and either Lamar Jackson or Gus Edwards
will fall forward and they'll get the
first down by like a yard right it's
it's totally different style of football
than we've seen yet 18 carries again
last week against the Bucs I don't know
that it's sustainable over a career I
definitely don't think that it might be
seen well over a season but for right
now they're winning with it it's been
successful it complements their really
good defense really well I think it
gives him a great chance to win tomorrow
night well this is their best defense
that he's facing by far I mean the other
defense is that he that he played
against Cincinnati Oakland Atlantic
Kansas City Tampa that right there not
walking through that door and StubHub on
Saturday but I mean he he has been
throwing the ball increasingly and
increasingly better as well and Greg
Roman the guy who had this offense for
Katherine yeah the guy who's dialing it
up on behalf of John Harbaugh right now
it is truly something that I think the
rape there's there's a there there I
really believe the Ravens have I kind of
believe they're gonna win this football
game best that's as close to the unlock
is lock as I can right there
well I've been tell I've been saying I
don't know if I'm gonna pick him to win
the game but with the point spread since
we were talking about that I love with
the Ravens with the point spread because
I do think they could win the game I
just love their mentality and the shame
of it to me rich is there's gonna be a
team in the AFC whether it's the Colts
or the Ravens maybe the Steelers
somebody's not gonna get in actually
think you're going to run I think it's
the Steelers bud you think they're gonna
lose they lose to New Orleans right um
and I think the Ravens or the Titans are
gonna win out and Wow and I thought
would put the Steelers at home can you
imagine Steelers finally beat Brady and
the Patriots and they lose and still
don't make the playoffs that would be
amazing it's a shame though because
I'd say four or five weeks ago I thought
maybe there's four teams in the hole on
the fella that could actually win the
Super Bowl right like Rams Saints Chiefs
Patriots now I'd say I think they're
both wide open man I can see a lot of
teams winning it all look the Chiefs we
all know right there's New England that
we all know it's amazing you know Chris
is who and what we just discussed with
with Brent you know when he talked about
what the flavor of the month is in the
desert right he talked about the
Chargers and now it's been the Saints
all season and it was the Chiefs for
quite some time and the Rams for quite
some time New England is totally
overlooked right now because Gronk is a
shadow of his former self yeah it's a
shame and that and that Josh Gordon is
now no longer here they just did in fact
lose to Pittsburgh which is kind of odd
lost to Tennessee Jacksonville and the
Lions but this is still the Patriots and
I think Houston loses in Philadelphia
not losing at home I think new in them
has has a home date in the second week
of the playoffs waiting form right now
right and then they presumably go in the
conference championship game let's say
they win that home game they've been
tough to beat all year at home then they
go to Kansas City or maybe to LA to play
the Chargers I don't know it's not like
either one of those are insurmountable
in a one-game situation that you can't
imagine the Patriots actually getting it
done they can't get it done in that one
game situation I don't see it happening
you don't know what do you think I mean
now yeah I've given you a whole bunch of
things Ross Tucker and it's time for you
to do you know one down on the table
yeah you know what I'm still gonna go
with the Chiefs I'm still gonna go with
the Chiefs I you know even when they've
lost the Patriots game the Chargers game
the Rams game they are right there we've
never seen anybody like mahomes I just
can't believe some of the things he does
and what's interesting and you know this
rich cuz you're all over the draft there
was a wide range of opinions on him when
he came out me some people watched him
and just couldn't understand how
unorthodox it was he didn't get anything
within the structure of the offense at
Texas Tech I'll still take the Chiefs I
don't feel good about it yeah I don't I
feel good about the Saints in the NFC I
picture a team with the way the saints
are playing I don't picture anybody
going to the Superdome and beating them
I feel really good about the Saints AFC
I'll still go Chiefs because I think
they win Sunday night I think they have
home-field advantage and I still think
mahomes can find a way to get it done
why do you feel so bullish on the Saints
who lost in Dallas needed fourth-quarter
rabbits to be pulled out of the right
off that struggling offensive a hat the
old line is banged up I I know why you'd
be bullish on the Saints but I want to
hear it from your mouth yeah so number
one how hard it is to win in the
Superdome and number two just how well
their defense is playing you know unlike
the Rams or the Chiefs the Saints can
win in other ways they can win on
defense they can win on special teams
and I still think at home Sean Payton
and Drew Brees are gonna figure out a
way rich to get 20 points on the board
and the way their defense is playing
right now I don't know people are gonna
get 20 points on the board on the Saints
down there dial up cam Jordans soundbite
from yesterday a few folks don't mind in
our Los Angeles broadcasting Center cuz
he he when he said it yesterday we were
on the air in the last half-hour and I
just knew that this was fodder for shows
like this one and it's gonna be chewed
up all morning on the Sports Talk
circuit this is what he had to say when
it was brought up to him what Ben
Roethlisberger coming into his house in
New Orleans this weekend with a Hall of
Fame resume they've got a quarterback
who might be going to the Hall of Fame
about in fact if you were in this area
you put a mat like a top three of this
area we put them on the top three bit
off the top five of this area you're
gonna go to the hole you put them at top
five of this area is that a yes or no
yes you put so you have blue plume you
top five
drupal Tom hey Ron hey Ron we've got
little holes in proper numbers are
impressive so you're saying numbers are
impressive these numbers are always
impressive hey Ron
okay so then we you put them right there
Peyton Manning this is your entire two
years ago that was most of
Roethlisberger's career you're saying
he's better he's better he's better than
Phillip Rivers right now career-wise
you because you give them a super bubble
not is that what you say okay so so you
put have a more coppers career than
Killebrew you're putting him at number
five okay I mean so okay I don't split
Eli before I put Ben but okay to suppose
if we were gonna buy his numbers exactly
except me like washed those do this
alright cool cool
so you putting him at number five what
do you make of that
Sylla look we and back and forth there
Ross well two things rich number one I I
don't really agree I mean I think he's
clearly top five clearly a Hall of Famer
based on how he's played but I'm just
surprised that cam would do that I mean
why would you do that I when you're
planning it's a team and by the way the
Steelers o-line they love Roethlisberger
they're gonna play hard for him I just
don't know why you would put more of a
bull's eye like if it was a quarterback
that I liked rich and you're always
gonna play hard you always want to win
you always want to be physical he is a
guy who sent a broom and a bottle of
your Jordan Cabernet to Cam Newton I
don't know if in Carroll I mean he's
entertaining I get it but I personally
would not put more of a bull's-eye on
myself when I'm about to go play against
a team that week why give them any extra
edge why fire them up even a little bit
more and why have guys like me coming to
cut you on bootlegs come in to hit you
as hard as I can trying to get you to
shut up
well I mean we did give credence to this
conversation yesterday Brockman and I
went back and forth and Peyton Manning
is absolutely
Jordan's credit in this era I mean yeah
Payton said since 2004 since the
drafting of Ben Roethlisberger it's been
Pitt yeah it was Brady Brees and Peyton
Manning right of the three that you can
stipulate yes Aaron Rodgers is in the
mix just because he's one of the yeah I
think he's a goat he's earned a boat
status despite having only one Super
Bowl and then it's it's take your pick
from the 2004 draft I think and it's
amazing how good that draft was even
through Kurt Warner's name out there
because Warner did have some time before
Oh for his his period with the Giants is
obviously no good compared to what he
did before and then after with Arizona
you look at the numbers on the screen
here between Big Ben Phillip and Eli
their passing yards are pretty much the
same the touchdowns Phillip has he's 20
clear of Ben and Eli is right around the
same the numbers are clearly in Ben's
win column and that includes the
playoffs where he's got 13 wins compared
to eight for Eli and Phillips under 500
playoff wise I mean don't you think rich
most people would have been as the best
out of that trio
I think Phillip and Eli is an
interesting discussion based on how
they're finishing their careers I think
most people would have been number one
out of those three I think so for
various reasons one is because Steeler
fans are everywhere yeah okay that's
number one and that's no disrespect to
the fan base of the Giants chargers
that's for instance he's played in the
most Super Bowls he's played in 3s he
also is a guy that is consistently
getting his team to the playoffs as
opposed to those two fellows Eli and
Phillip so that's why but when it all
comes down to it people kind of like
bashing on Big Ben cuz he's always
saying one sentence too many in his
press conferences there's always some
he's earned that right though rich he's
earned that right you're saying that you
know it's funny it's ironic that cam
Jordan saying those things where I just
say what's the upside to saying it when
I never understood the upside the Big
Ben publicly calling out some of his
teammates so maybe maybe turn it
turnabout's fair play for big bet I
don't know it was another name that we
didn't really talk about yesterday but
he is in this era maybe doesn't have the
postseason success it's Tony Romo Tony
Romo has a two to one touchdown
interception ratio in 30 games over 500
career record but you're know I mean his
numbers are obviously some of the best
in the history of the Dallas Cowboys but
you can't you can't throw him as a
top-five quarterback in the era would
you kick one of the 2004 quarterbacks
out of the mix or Romo over Aaron
Rodgers really you can't take Rome over
Eli I was gonna say that I that's
interesting because I think there are
some people that would say if you knew
what you knew now and you were drafting
an expansion team in 2004 would you
rather have Eli or Romo I think a lot
people to pick Romo and I love Tony Romo
I love everything about those numbers
are so much better than even the reason
why Tony Romo is a terrific broadcaster
is not because he's so effusive and not
because he is the guy at the end of the
bar that's what puts him over the top
between good and terrific what puts him
in the mix is a great broadcast is his
incredible knowledge of the game yep and
his X's and O's awareness is off the
children okay one so I put him top five
in terms of that but you can I mean it's
just as it's so easy to kick Eli because
of his lack of success outside of the
Superbowl season correct of consistent
CSS his dorkface
all of that stuff that everyone loves to
make funny Eli but Eli Manning is an
all-time great quarterback in the
history of the NFL and when you talk
about yes it yes or
games over 500 he's 116 and 112 he is
got two rings and has been dynamite for
a franchise there's the only one that
can raise their hands and say we put an
L in the column of Brady and Belichick
in the era of Brady and Belichick the
goat quarterback and the coast coach
period an exposed of thank you for
corrected I just I got I got in a New
York role right here I got in a New York
role please you i Romo over Eli you're
just saying that because you think you
would have beaten Tony Romo on those
Super Bowls I'm saying we the Patriots
lost those Super Bowls to Michael
Strahan and OC y Manning I'm lucky
Brady makes the Manningham was
unbelievably makes that throw you're
talking about that's the goat that's it
right there when he goes in the Hall of
Fame you know I broke those tackles to
make that throw I'm just saying I think
if you ask some coaches and they were
starting expansion franchise I do think
some of them would rather have Romo
although I'll tell you where they really
lose it Chris Romo's durability in the
back issues sure Eli
Iron Man Man Iron Man you know Ben
McAdoo was the only guy that could stop
him Ben McAdoo was right though Ben
McAdoo was right to pull the plug on Eli
and the Giants are suffering because of
it Ross Tucker good to see you here
before we didn't even get to you pound
in the table for Taylor Swift over
prints I mean what else is really say
it's pretty clear isn't it pretty
obvious oh my mom look I understand
everybody always talks about I know
Prince is a very talented musician I get
it okay you can't just you can't just
say give the caveat look Taylor Swift is
a very talented musician right and she
is a hugely popular
for for a ton for a ton of yeah there's
ik fans yes you know I understand that
she's she's she's an icon to not your
demographic she's a young girl right I
am admit I am as willingly fine for you
to love Taylor Swift right no problem
you were and you are at every right to
love Taylor Swift but you cannot not
very fine musician away Prince I'm just
saying like what are his but what's your
favorite race Mount Rushmore musician
but I'm not comparing them as musicians
comparing their music oh and I much
prefer Taylor Swift songs 10 Prince
songs if I got in a car and Purple Rain
came on I would turn the channel if
wildest dreams by Taylor Swift came on I
would rock out because that song oh my
god I would rock it out because that
song is awesome and I can give you like
five Taylor Swift songs but I think
Prince's music is overrated I can
appreciate you know the culture and the
genre and a bunch of big words my tiny
brain doesn't care about I care about
when I turn the radio on how it goes to
my ears it makes my brain feel and
Taylor Swift songs make my brain feel
better than print songs it's that simple
a lot of direct messages I got a lot of
text messages people would say dude I
would never admit this publicly by
totally agree
oh yeah but Swift these are nuts Ross
Tucker the Ross Tucker podcasts on
podcast one where you can get where you
can get this podcast
my wife's is the Lakers podcast Suzie
yes Shaq we got to find out about that
fact ask Shaq I was listening to you
guys yesterday did in fact ask Shaq what
he thought about that
she said the response was more nuanced
than anything else jack knows my stay
right there Ross why you got one more
segment with you I'm not done with you
yet Ross Tucker Ross Tucker here on the
Rich Eisen show one more segment with
Ross when we come back
ask the poll question of Ross Tucker
here Chris okay Ross here's what we got
today what's the most likely scenario
when we return on December 31st we're
all ok Oklahoma faces Notre Dame in the
college football final okay no the
Eagles are in the playoffs okay
the Chargers win the AFC West the Texans
get a first-round bye
the Lakers are the number one team in
the three and a half first place so okay
they have six games between now and then
Manny Machado is in New York Yankee I
would say the most likely of those as
Manny Machado is a Yankee but by the way
you gotta know this I'm from
Philadelphia okay they really want Manny
Machado but the latest report I saw this
morning is that if it's close he wants
to go to the Yankees so I see all these
Philly fans saying don't make it close
don't make it close so we want to sign a
guy that says he's not Johnny hustle and
would rather be a Yankee and they just
want to blow him out of the water with
more money that seemed like the least
Philadelphia thing ever
but I think he's probably end up being
yeah I would say that's number one
number two would be I might even say
Eagles make the playoffs I think he was
gonna be the Texans and Redskins day too
now the Viking I don't know if the
Vikings gonna lose bite they're gonna
lose at Detroit or home to the Bears for
who might need that game to get the two
seat yeah I see I think the Bears are a
better team and the Vikings yes Bears
are gonna I think the Bears might lose
to the Niners keep put a pin in that one
put a pin in that one cuz I'm giving
another Pontius lock of the week show
actually the most the most unfill
Adelphia thing of all time is somebody
from the area the suburbs pounding the
table for Taylor Swift over Prince
that's a very Philadelphia thing before
I let you go sir we've been asking this
question of our guests the last couple
of days your bowl game name is the last
place you shopped okay plus the last
thing you ate and and then add the ball
game we just asked that of Brent
Musburger earlier this hour and he gave
the name of a
local discount liquor shop and stop
right there and I think he threw out his
favorite food which was an enum and had
that this morning for breakfast that
said last place you shopped plus the
last thing you ate yeah I don't shot
very often but I do know what I took my
daughter's to get some Christmas gifts
so it would be the target
avocado omelet Bowl Oh target avocado
I'm gonna like it man pretty good one
the target avocado omelet Bowl yeah that
one California feelin healthy
throw some avocado that's what Brady
would do very tv12 of you Ross yes all
right we'll have a great call what you
calling the game with on Westwood one
Brandon Gordon and Olivia Harlan
Olivia Decker Kevin's daughter yes right
now and you tweet during radio
broadcasts man I noticed that I'm
listening I do sometimes I mean yeah
you're multitasking
yeah well definitely when I'm on the
sideline because they don't come to me
as much as I want to come to me so
definitely I'm on the sideline not as
much when I'm in the booth but sometimes
I'm in the booth you Ross Tucker NFL
catch the rock Ross Tucker podcast on
podcast one check him out on the radio
Ravens and chargers on Westwood One on
Saturday thanks for coming in here sir
have me rings at any time the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience